Has it ever occurred to you,
as you walk down the street,
just how much data is flowing
beneath your feet?
A wealth of information
on our health and our well-being
is running through our city sewers,
and we're all contributing to it
every single time we use the toilet.
Think about it.
Everybody pees and poops,
and we know that urine and stool
contain a rich source of information
on our health and our well-being.
Our doctors look at it all the time
to analyze for a variety of things.
Now, every time you flush,
you're sending this valuable information
down into our sewers,
where it's mixing with waste from hundreds
of thousands of other people.
Once collected, it looks
something like this.
This tiny sample
comes from a wastewater treatment plant
that represents more
than one million people.
And from it, we can detect all sorts
of things about that community:
the infectious disease viruses
that are circulating in our bodies,
chemical markers for the drugs
that are most commonly consumed.
And we can analyze for all the bacteria
that live in our collective microbiomes.
Now, if this sounds too close for comfort,
just consider all the personalized data
that you're parting with every day
when you use gadgets like
your smartphone or your smart watch.
What's amazing about sewage
is that it's naturally
aggregated and anonymized.
Once flushed,
your waste is mixing with that
of thousands and thousands of people,
so there's actually no way
to tie any information from here
back to a specific person.
Put differently,
it's the perfect data dump.
(Laughter)
The thoughtful collection
and analysis of sewage
has the potential to radically
improve health outcomes
in cities around the world,
and it's a growing field
called "wastewater epidemiology."
And wastewater epidemiology
is but one example
of all the big data that we're
generating in our cities today.
Consider all the data that you generate
with every phone call, package delivered,
mile driven.
It's data from cameras, sensors, drones,
air quality, water quality monitoring,
and the vast amounts of information
generated by our health care
and our educational systems.
All of this information,
these digital breadcrumbs,
tell us unique stories about our cities
and the way that we live our lives.
The thoughtful collection
and analysis of this information
has the power to inform
real-time improvements
to things like social policy,
environmental management,
health equity and more.
As an architect, I believe
that we need to harness
the hundreds of millions
of terabytes of data
that we're generating in our cities
each and every day.
And this is important now more than ever,
because for the first time
in human history,
more than half of all people
live in cities.
By 2050,
this number will grow
to nearly seven in 10 people.
Now just think about what
that means for a second.
It means our biggest crises,
from climate change to pandemics
to growing inequality,
are going to hit cities first and hardest.
But the era of big data
offers an opportunity
for new and creative solutions
to tackle these problems.
So let's dive into the opportunity
presented by wastewater epidemiology.
Some of you may have heard of it
as it gained a lot of popularity
and attention during
the COVID-19 pandemic.
In 2020, research groups
from around the world
began detecting SARS-CoV-2 RNA,
the virus that causes COVID-19,
in sewage samples.
I was on one of those teams.
We and others showed
that you can actually use sewage
as an accurate representation
of COVID activity in our communities.
Let me show you what I mean.
Here we're looking at a time series
over the course of the pandemic.
So from March 2020 through just last week.
The blue line represents COVID virus
concentrations in sewage samples
from across the United States.
In yellow, we see COVID
clinical case data.
For the first two years of the pandemic,
case data was very reliable.
People were getting
PCR-tested all the time.
During those two years,
the two data sets tracked very well.
That was great.
It meant that sewage was also reliable
and an accurate representation
of disease burden.
However, over the past
year and a half to two years,
we've seen a divergence
in those data sets.
People just aren't getting
COVID-tested nearly as often.
Sewage, on the other hand,
doesn't require us
to access health care services.
We're all represented just
by peeing and pooping.
Throughout the pandemic, we and others
also showed that sewage is predictive
and a leading indicator
of new COVID clinical cases.
This is because infectious disease
viruses incubate in our bodies
before we develop symptoms
or go get tested.
Meanwhile, we've been excreting
the virus for days.
During COVID,
it was shown that sewage
was anywhere between one to three weeks
leading indicator for clinical cases.
Now I'm going to show you an example
of one time that this led
to a big community-impacting decision.
Here, we're looking at data
from the Boston area
during the Omicron wave.
In December 2021,
towards the end of the month,
COVID cases began to skyrocket
across the country
and didn't slow until the end of January.
Boston Children's Hospital,
though, was ready.
They had been looking
at Boston area sewage
and saw the sewage levels
go up weeks earlier,
so they proactively postponed
all non-emergency medical procedures.
They wanted to free up resources
so that they could adequately respond
to the incoming wave of hospitalizations.
Now wastewater epidemiology has been used
to tackle other pressing
health issues as well.
Before the pandemic,
the biggest public health crisis
in the United States
was our growing drug epidemic.
Drug overdoses were growing year over year
and had become the leading
cause of accidental death
for Americans under the age of 50.
In 2018, a small town in North Carolina
had seen overdoses go up,
and they wanted better information,
better data to know what to do about it,
what was driving this trend
and how to respond.
So we turned to the sewers,
and together with the mayor's office,
we began to analyze sewage samples
from several sites across the city
and were able to show
that prescription opioids
were the drug most commonly consumed,
not injectable opioids.
Equipped with this data,
the city diverted resources
from needle exchange sites
and put that money into medication
takeback programs instead.
They advertised and held
dozens of town halls
where they talked about the adverse
effects of prescription painkillers.
That year,
the city saw a 40 percent
reduction in overdoses,
and for the first time,
they had engaged their community
in a dialogue around drugs,
addiction and overdose.
Now imagine if every city around the world
had access to this sort of information.
Before the pandemic,
wastewater epidemiology was a tiny field
with no more than a dozen
experts worldwide.
Today, 72 countries
have used wastewater monitoring
to understand COVID-19.
And it's time that we leverage
these investments
to monitor for all sorts
of other things as well.
Imagine knowing when influenza
and RSV are going to peak every year
so that our hospitals can prepare.
Imagine mapping nutrition in our cities
so that we can identify food deserts
and understand social
determinants of health.
Imagine identifying superbugs
and antibiotic resistant genes
as they emerge in our communities.
Imagine preventing the next pandemic
before it happens.
In the way that cholera prompted London
to build modern-day sewer systems,
and poor health in the tenements
of New York City
were one of the catalysts behind
the building of Central Park,
this is how our cities
can learn from COVID-19.
And this is precisely how we can foster
a new, intelligent kind of urbanization.
For years now, scientists, policymakers,
architects and urban planners
have been harnessing the power
of technology and big data
to future-proof our cities.
Over the last decade,
chief technology officers
have been appointed in cities
around the world.
Roles once reserved for the boardrooms
and hallways of Silicon Valley
are now finally open in city hall.
So next time you swipe your credit card,
take a ride in a taxi
or tap your MetroCard,
just consider how you're contributing
to your city's ever-growing
digital infrastructure.
And next time you use the toilet,
just remember, you're doing
your civic duty.
(Laughter)
Thank you.
(Applause)